παντού στην ευρώπη και που στέλνουμε τέλος πάντω τώρα όμως έχουν επιτύχει πολύ μεγάλα πράγματα
ογιατί τους ίνονται διάφορα κίνη υμερα και μεγάλα κίνετερα καιλευτά με πολύ χαμιλεί μεχαμηλώ τόπο
αυτό του πρόεγμα πρέπει να γίνεί δε στη κύπρο δεν πρέπει να γίνουν πολλές δομιχανίες
γιατί δεν υπάρχει ούτε το προσωπικό για να καλήψει ένα μεγάλο αριθμό φαρμακοπεοιχανιών εκείνο το
οποίο μπορεί να κάνικανείς είναι να στηρίξει τις υπάρχουνσες να δημιουργήσουν νέα προϊόντα νέες γραμμές
προϊόντω γιατί υπάρχουν πάρα πολλά πρόδιπατους χάλι θα μπορούσαμε βί να κάνουμε φάρμακα για τα
μάτια ιτα οποία δεν παράγομε τώρα άλλες ωταρίες θα μπορούσαν τα να πουν στην παραγωγή
νασίμουν προϊόντων οι εμβολύ προσχωρίς οι εμπολίων ι παρομείονάλλων μπορούν να γίνουν πάρα πολλαπράγοτα με
τρομακτικές με ιεφίσεις τα έλεγα στο θέματων εξαγογών διοδί θα μπορούσαμε να διπλασιάσουμε τι να
την πλασιάσουμε τις εξαγωγές σε πέτεοιδεκά χρόνια αν ερχόταν ν αρογός η κυβέρνηση στε κοντά
στοοσιενές εκατόν τω βιομιχανικών εξαπογών της κύπρα δεν κάνοολάενομίζιοκιμένο τη μεταεξήκου ευτά κοσιγια γαταιρεία σας
αν έριξε την αθεκτικό ητας σε πολλές πρόκλησης που βρήκε μπροστάτης θεωρείται ότι υπάρχουν απόμ
προπτικές ανάπτυξης γερα απε αυτό τον δομέα